I would like to start
with the very beginning
about your work in the exhibition
Mood Disorder,
and ask you perhaps
to describe the work.
Mood Disorder is an artist book
and it shows basically what happens
when I put a photograph of myself
kind of like this
in this kind of generic stock pose
of what depression would look like,
and I put that
onto the Wikipedia page
for Mood disorder.
I was kind of playing
these stereotypes
of how depression looks
in stock imagery.
That's what influenced me
to make that image.
Websites, journalists,
bloggers began to use it
because they could legally use
these copyright-free images.
They don't have to pay royalties.
And they began to use it
to illustrate mental health issues,
depression, sadness,
anti-depressant pill articles.
And then what I did was
I used Google reverse image,
or I took the image
and did the reverse image search
and re-found all of these articles
that had used my image.
The Mood Disorder piece
is the image in –
I don't like to say circulation
because it's not really.
It's more like propagation.
So it's the image
propagating over the internet
maybe changing the black-and-white,
changing color, getting cropped
going into different languages.
Danish, Norwegian, German,
Arabic and Thai I think I found.
And then using Google,
I collected all of these sites
and then made this artist book.
So what does it mean for an artist
to actually claim ownership
for something
that is so widely distributed?
I think authorship,
to author a work,
is to kind of delineate an artwork
and say like this is an artwork
that I'm entering
into a kind of public discourse
on photography or art making.
And it's just a way
of defining an artwork.
For me, I don't really believe
in maybe what the author meant
a hundred years ago,
that the author is the sole creator,
because lots of people helped
in the production of this work
that aren't being credited.
How do you feel that photography
has changed in the 21st century
with this further increase
both in the production
but also circulation of images?
It’s so complicated
because photography is everywhere.
People today almost use photography
to almost perform themselves
for the public.
So when people are on Instagram
or on Twitter,
the images they make are like
an extension of their sensibility
that they're sharing
with the worldwide web.
It's like saying who they are,
which I don't think
that was the case before.
Like for me,
I'm using Wikipedia,
and that's specifically
a copyright-free website,
so these are images
that can freely circulate.
And so in my project,
I'm playing with that space
of open circulation.
I'm actually participating
with Wikipedia
how like a normal user would.
You upload images,
which I think is relevant.
But in this process
a lot of Wikipedia editors
caught on to what I was doing,
and over a course of a few years
there were these discussions,
conversations
which ended up with me
being officially banned.
And after that ban became official
the Mood Disorder image was taken off
of the Mood disorder web page
and so it no longer circulates
from Wikipedia
but it still will circulate
from the internet, hopefully, maybe.